Adam is attempting to beat the world
record for the most cracks with two
whips in one minute I really feel for
the guy who has to count these whipping
Adam how is he doing that that's amazing
he's done it Adam whipped up an amazing
568 cracks in 60 seconds crushing the
previous record by 38 cracks we flew
into Texas to meet this whip-cracking
supremo and all-around showman I started
whip cracking when I was 9 years old
after I saw Indiana Jones and the Last
Crusade my dad made me my first whip out
of rope and I wanted to get a better
whip so then I started making my own
whips so the object of this trick is to
crack the whip precisely on the playing
cards knock them out from underneath the
egg and have the egg fall into the mug
but some people are just more impressed
when I explode the egg whip cracking
world can be a little bit competitive
especially when it comes to world record
here I'll demonstrate my most recent
world record the end of the whip has to
hit right on the bottle cap for it to
work
what is the science behind Adams to whip
world record cracking a whip is hard
enough but Adam has to do it quickly and
repeatedly he actually gets a crack on
both the back and the forward movement
and he keeps going so quickly the whip
never gets a chance to go slack to
create a whip crack you need to make a
sonic boom that means the end of the
whip needs to move faster than the speed
of sound even Adam can't move his arm
that fast so there's something else
going on here to get the whip cracking
the way you break the sound barrier with
a whip is you need to start pushing a
loop down the whip very quickly and that
loop has some momentum now momentum is
mass times speed and the momentum won't
change as it goes along the whip since a
whip is tapered the mass of the whip
gets less as it goes down towards the
tip this means the loop that travels
down the whip ends up losing mass but
for the momentum to stay the same it
needs to get faster when the loop ends
up at the end of the whip the tip of the
whip can be traveling up to 32 times
faster than the original flick of the
handle the only thing cooler than a whip
cracks
it's a whip crack on fire